capitalism has a lot of problems there
are a lot of inequities there are a lot
of things about it that are imperfect
and should be tweaked and should be
fixed but capitalism is the you know has
created a a world in those countries
that practice it where if you have a
great idea you can raise some money and
you can go do it and certainly the
personal computer and consumer digital
revolution of the last thirty years
would never have happened if it weren't
for free markets people's ability to
from any walk of life to come up with an
idea do it in a garage get a little
money from some venture capitalists or
somebody and then bring it to market and
if it fails and most of them do fail you
know you go try something else and if it
succeeds you could become the wealthiest
guy in the world like Bill Gates did and
I think you can't overstate the
importance of a free-market economic
system and particularly the way it has
been practiced in the United States
where people are willing both
technologists and investors have been
willing to take risks sometimes you've
lost money on those risks we saw it in
the dot-com bubble and then a bust of of
just a six or seven years ago but
overall it's been an extremely
invigorating and and healthy thing and
even in other capitalist countries where
risk-taking was harder and where failure
was much more of a kind of final thing
they didn't they didn't spawn the kinds
of ideas and products and technologies
that we did because it's not a sin to
fail in the United States certainly not
in tech I can tell you that people come
to
me everyday with companies and products
who came to see me five years before for
some completely different company and
product which may have failed maybe it
succeeded but a lot of times it failed
and I don't say well I'm not gonna see
that guy because he failed in his last
company and the venture capitalists
don't say well you failed in your last
company why should we even listen to you
no they say ok you learn something from
that failure
let's listen in your new